- All right, y'all, before we go,
let's take a quick dive into
the world of social media.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat jazzy music)
(audience cheers)
The holidays can be mostly magical,
but for some of us, extra time with family
means a few extra curse words.
It happen.
That's where Auntie Bev comes in.
(Kelly laughs)
This former journalist
and educator started a TikTok channel
teaching vocabulary words.
She's encouraging everyone
to curse with class
this holiday season.
Nice.
(air wisps)
- So, you wanna call somebody a ho,
(audience laughs)
they're licentious.
You wanna call somebody a (beep),
they are viragos or termagants.
If you wanna call a man a ho,
(Auntie Bev laughs)
'cause there's some
male hos out there, too.
Those can be either louts,
L-O-U-T or lotharios.
You're just a lothario.
(audience cheers)
- I love her!
Let's get Auntie Bev in here!
She's watching on WRAL
TV in Raleigh-Durham.
What's up?
(audience cheers)
- Hey, Kelly! Hi, how are you?
- Oh my... I am obsessed with
you, I'm gonna lead with that.
I do know some louts.
So you're trying to help
at Christmas time, right?
- Absolutely, because I
don't know about your family,
but let me tell you about my family.
Full disclosure here.
(Auntie Bev laughs)
We have those family members who come over
and, you know, they've
already had a lot to drink.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And they come over
and they have more eggnog
and they just become totally obnoxious
and you wanna bite your tongue
because you know you
want to cuss them out.
Not curse them out-
- Yeah.
- [Auntie Bev] Because
cursing is the formality.
Cuss them out is the hood version.
(audience laughs)
So, when you want to cuss them out,
you call them a lummox.
Just ask them to just stop being a lummox.
We don't need that.
So, what do you want to tell Grandma
as opposed to just being
upset and saying, you know,
"Grandma, you need to
sit your (censored) down
and shut up."
(audience laughs)
Say, "Grandma, this is your day.
You don't need to be a harridan."
Now, a harridan is a bossy, strict,
old, belligerent woman.
(audience laughs)
Instead of saying that-
- Oh my God!
- You just say, "Grandma,
don't be a harridan."
And then you have the
male cousins who come over
and they're hitting on everybody
until they realize you're their cousin.
(audience laughs)
They're lotharios, so you just say,
"Hey, look, lothario.
I'm your cousin!
I'm your sister's niece."
So you have to come up with
a lot of different classier words-
- [Kelly] I like it.
- In order to say
the same kinds of things you would say
when you're using the four,
five-letter nasty words.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yes.
Here's the thing, I wish that
I were spending Christmas
with you because you are hysterical,
I like the words, I like it.
Sometimes you need the real ones,
but try and keep it classy, America, okay?
Thank you so much, Auntie Bev!
(audience cheers)
I'm liking your post right now!
(alert dings)
(audience cheers)
That's not all, though.
Our season-long partner Pilot,
pen-makers of Precise, the go-to pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate people
who make the holidays a little
less dramatic and more fun,
and that is you, ma'am.
So they're giving you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much, Auntie Bev!
Have such a great holiday season!